this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
i'm a superhero congratulations on this
film
it is everything i literally googled do
they were crocs in jail
after watching it fascinating
they do
my first question to you is about harley
quinn you know this is the third time
we're seeing her i think this is the
coolest we've ever seen her
what did you want to bring to her
character this time around and why
well let me it's a very interesting
question because
i have sort of made my career off of
taking superheroes
that don't have much to them
in the comic books who have changed a
lot you know don't really have and then
sort of transforming them into a
different personality on screen
you read see groot in the first movie
you read groot and the comic books and
they're nothing alike you know
star-lord was constantly changing his
personality for years and years in the
comics and then he became what he is in
the movies
and now those things in the comics are
in the movies are aligned
i felt that harley quinn is one of the
greatest written comic book characters
of all time i think she belongs on the
wall with
you know really well written characters
like batman over the years
daredevil uh spiderman
wonder woman who sort of have very
specific personalities
and that goes back to pauldini who wrote
the original
harley for the animated series and so i
just really wanted to embody that
fully and give us full chaotic trickster
crazy harley 100 no apologies
and i hope that's what we got but at the
same time also allowing her to learn
some things
in her own crazy way she becomes a
better person
yeah we definitely got that and i love
that we got to see like a glamorous side
to her you nailed it
let's talk about the mcu in dc you're
the only director that's done both
first question in this set is you know
the suicide squad versus guardians of
the galaxy who do you think would win
and the second one is how did you
approach this film
you know knowing that it was going to be
a different world than the mcu but still
keeping your james gunn voice like how
did you do that
yeah i mean listen to me in some ways
the guardians and
suicide squad feel it you know could be
at home
with each other as much as anything
one's a pg-13 movie
the other one's an r-rated movie but in
both cases i'm making a james gun movie
first in a dc or marvel movie second now
that's the way i approach it um and
uh and i think that's why you know
things changed in
you know in so many ways after i came on
board
um but uh what was oh who would win in a
fight i don't know i mean listen
the guardians are outer space people
with a lot of
weaponry alien tech at their disposable
it's not exactly a fair fight
you know coconut man however is
incredibly powerful and could
wipe out the entire guardians perhaps by
himself
so let's just call it a draw because i
don't know what to do but i would love
to see it on screen anyway
speaking of polkadot man this cast is
just like an island of the best misfit
toys ever
how did you pick characters in the dc
canon like did you just go through the
comics you're like i'm gonna find the
wackiest villain
in here i did i went through well
for instance polkadot man i just looked
up online dumbest super villain
ever and there's a ton of clickbait
lists all over the internet and polkadot
man
is at the top of all of them and i said
i gotta redeem poke it out man
i gotta give you know poke it out man
his
shot at glory in which i hope that i did
you know i knew
when dc came to me and said what project
do you want you could do anything you
want
i you know i knew that somebody else was
gonna do a superman movie
i knew no one was ever going to do a
polkadot man movie so i thought i had my
opportunity
but i really just went through the whole
dc catalog they have this
incredibly dense and beautiful you know
trove of costumed oddballs
over the past 75 years and i made copies
of all the
characters that i thought might be
interesting and kind of went through
with them and just whittled them away
until i got to
the characters that i thought would help
my story the most
you are just such a genius polka dot man
is literally my favorite next to
weasel and savant why did you turn your
brother into a weasel
and did you purposely put michael rooker
in that opening sequence to mess with
him
well i definitely put him in the long
white wig to mess with him i
love the idea of seeing rooker as uh
edgar winter
froze like the 70s albino uh rock
rockstar
but i just thought he would be funny in
the wig so that's really why he was cast
as saban
which is totally not a very a very
shallow reason but that's the reason
and uh my brother my brother can just do
things that no one can do like
he has a way of moving a way of acting
like all those sounds that weasel make
that's my brother making those sounds
like he is
crazy so being able to give him this
character who is one of my favorite
characters
uh because he is not at all cute in any
traditional
sense he is a mess um and he is no
smarter than a greyhound
so i thought that sean would be perfect
to play him
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team idris my first
question is for you
because i feel like bloodsport is going
to be a fan favorite after people see
this film so are you
already talking about the next time
we're gonna see him
uh nice um thank you first of all for
getting the memo
about the color coordination with the
hat
am i loving that um listen man i'm so
excited that people
were liking the character um we haven't
you know talked about what comes next
but you know the the possibilities are
infinite um and um
i'm really excited for audiences to lead
that process to kind of tell us
what they want to see come next you know
well i feel like when they leave this
movie after learning that bloodsport
puts superman into the icu
everyone's going to want to see him
fight superman so do you want to see
that
of course i do that's a great story and
we need to we'd love to see that happen
see that story be told uh well i hope it
does
from your lips to god's ears um daniella
ratcatcher 2
is such a lovable character she made me
want to like call my dad after the film
what is what was your relationship with
rats you know did you train with them
did you have to work with any real rats
or did you learn anything about them
that made them like any less creepy
um actually they're pretty intelligent i
i didn't know that um until i got to
work with them
i was i didn't have like an opinion
about them before
uh starting to work with them and now i
just love rats and i follow like many
accounts of people that
uh like have rats has pets
and i can show you really quick a photo
of me
on set with sebastian
wait was sebastian a real rat yeah we
had three rats on set
and they were rotating all the time and
they were trained like to stay on my
shoulder and to be like behaved
wow idris were you scared were you
freaked out about them in real life
yeah no definitely yes
yes um you know i
definitely grew with my character in
um the sort of trajectory of falling in
love with the rats because
daniella was one of my best friends on
set so
i would want to hang out with her on set
but she'd always have this rat it was an
awkward thing between us
but i had to get used to it um but one
thing i will tell you is that you know
she had three different rats that would
circulate
but they all had the same um
rat perks it was you know it was
ratified
you had that one saved in your arsenal
and you were just waiting to get it out
what was it like working with james gone
you guys uh james gunn was
a really good experience from start to
finish you know i met him
in a hotel room you know in la really
late at night when he was uh
you know telling me what the story was
about and you know his passion
for for that in the casting process
was equal to his passion the last time i
saw him which is on a zoom doing the
press
you know this guy lives eats breathes
this
this storytelling and and the suicide
squad and
and you know it was just amazing to
watch him do it
and i learned a lot i want to direct one
day i learned a lot from him
wow what about you daniella i was
blown away by his passion about making
movies by
like how how an amazing human being he
is
and yeah for me it was like a six-month
master class that i can't wait to
go back to his school and to learn more
he's he's like a genius for me
wow everyone's been saying such great
things about him and all the characters
are just so
incredibly lovable in their own way is
there a character aside from your own
that you guys just nerd out on or that
you nerded out on
on set i loved um ratcatcher 2
because you know she reminds me
of my daughter who is 19
who is you know very funny and dry
humid and and uh and rat catcher is
a daddy's goal as like my daughters is
so
you know yeah i love harley quinn
i just admire how many energy she has
i wish i could have like that energy
every day
um and i love king shark too because
yeah i feel sorry for him because he
didn't have friends
i know made me so sad i love that you
were like his friend
oh and bloodsport also no
actually many people have been asking me
like if i went on a mission
who would i choose and if it was just
only one
one person i'm always saying like blood
sport because it's
my best mate we're here to save you you
were gonna save
me it was a really good plan too i can
go back inside and you can still do it
that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport margot my first
question is for you
third time we're seeing harley quinn you
know and people are
loving this exploration of her what do
you think james gunn
brought to her character and what is it
that you wanted to add to her this time
around
i think she's just at a very different
place in her life we're seeing a more
independent harley independent of mr j
that is
um she she's a little boy crazy uh she's
definitely single and ready to mingle in
this film
um and that was very fun because there's
a lot of comics where i love
watching harley try and have a dating
life um
but she's also in work mode i mean this
movie kicks off and
within the mission begins it's not
working up to a mission and it's not
uh you know like this movie gets going
like two minutes in
[ __ ] hits the fan and you're kind of
like wait
i feel like we're breaking all the rules
that i normally see in a comic book film
and now i don't know
what like anything could happen and i
think that's an exciting place uh
to for the characters to start in and
it's also an exciting place just for the
audiences to jump into it
yes i love that um david
i don't know if you're ready for the
fandom that polka dot man is about to
have because i've been talking to people
it's gonna be insane i'm definitely
gonna be poking out man for halloween
um coolest prosthetics i've ever seen on
film what
what was that you know can you tell me
more about that and what were you
playing to were you throwing like
colorful discs
so first of all i'm so glad you
recognized the makeup work that they did
james
gunn is such a genius on so many levels
but one of the things he really insisted
on with this film
was he wanted it to be visceral and he
wanted it to be tangible and he wanted
the audience to really experience things
in a dangerous and exciting way so
he really insisted on practical effects
as much as possible
the legacy effects team that designed
the polka dot man prosthetics
blew my mind i mean i'm a guy who grew
up watching lon chaney i always wanted
to be that actor i wanted to be someone
who could you know be the phantom of the
opera it could be the hunchback of notre
dame and then when i got to become
abner in polkadot man mode it was like
ah i couldn't it was such a dream um
and you know when we were when we were
on set i just
i guess i used the power of my bizarre
weird imagination
to see things you know shooting out of
me but
one thing that was such a cool touch was
when my gauntlets would
pop open and i'd get ready to expel the
polka dots from my body they
glowed with this really cool eerie glow
that made me feel
powerful i don't play a lot of
characters that have moments of power
and it was such an exceptional
experience to stand there and feel like
i could just do a lot of damage right
now it was really cool
wow both your characters are so specific
but so universal i relate to them
so hardcore so thank you guys for
vulnerably going there because i
definitely felt it
what was it like working with james gunn
and what was your favorite part about
shooting this film we'll start with you
margo
i mean he's a genius he i i've never
seen someone
execute at such a big
level like the scope of this film is
insane it's it's i think
people don't really appreciate how hard
it is to run a set at
that is that size um and he
orchestrates it all beautifully and
creates an atmosphere where you feel
safe but you can try things but
everyone's having fun and everyone's
joking and it's
mental and it's bonkers and it's so much
of it you know he really want had a
practical approach so
we didn't have to rely on like we
weren't looking at tennis balls a lot of
the time being like i guess an
explosion's gonna you know it's like
things were blowing up in our faces it
was just incredible
incredible he's he's such a genius he's
so prepared
he's such a lovely person it was yeah it
was a dream and
also i love the cast very much in
particular david doesn't alchin
um i gotta say i've known james
personally for years i think that he's
such an exceptional dude and such a
genius and he has such vision
and um but it's it's an odd thing when
you're friends with people
at least with james and i it just we
never talked about work we talked about
comic books we talked about movies we
talked about things that we liked
we definitely never talked about work
and i never i guess i didn't know
in what way creatively that our paths
would cross until one day
randomly he invites me to be in his film
i mean i'd
i'd acted in a film he'd written in the
past but i'd never actually
i didn't i don't know i just i always
would in the back of my head go gosh it
would be so cool james ever wanted to
direct me in something
so when i showed up to set i didn't know
how the dynamic was going to work with
somebody that i already knew so well
um and it was a dream and i had a couple
of um
i've been so blessed as an actor to work
with directors who might trust and who
can really help
me guide my way through some tricky
moments and i had a couple of them on
this film and
um james really did everything that i
dreamed that a director would do and um
it was just a beautiful experience and
i'm like i'm margot robbie's biggest fan
um so being in a film with her
ever since i filmed tarzan i've got to
say i've just been
hard off for her i've got a little
shrine in the back of my closet with
some candles
and um don't tell her she's not on the
zoom right now is she is she on our zoo
oh shoot
that's so weird i have a margot ravi
shrine too i love her
who doesn't dude lady monk i wonder who
doesn't if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early although that
isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
joel it is so nice to have you solo
today
so honored uh
i don't know don't worry about it i
never get tired of that joel
the joke is i'm actually a real
superhero in real life
i've actually crafted the power to be
invisible yeah
like yo i know she's doing an interview
with john cena but like why is she
talking to nobody
it's actually very well played that was
very well played
how to do you can't see it you can't see
john cena joke love it i'm so excited to
talk to you guys joel
though if you watch the movie it's uh my
eyes are up here bro
joel first question is for you you know
your character is coming back from the
first film so what did you want to bring
to your character that we didn't see in
the first film to this one
well i mean i love the version of the
character that james wrote
so when i sat down with james you know
one of our first real
creative conversations i i told him that
i didn't
really feel like i wanted to be
artistically bound
by what i did in the first film i wanted
to just
let the character be what it is in this
you know
universe and um and i i i i
had a lot more fun with it this time
around i felt like i got looser and
the character was a little more
idealistic less cynical
was a little bit more engaged with the
other characters
so i like this version yeah i like this
version too i'm excited for everyone to
see it and
everyone obviously to me peacemaker it's
gonna be
such a hit john it's obviously so nice
to see you i'm so excited that
peacemaker is getting a spin-off show
how do you want to see your character
evolve in that spin-off show when we get
to see it in january
well first off i would love people to be
entertained by the suicide squad and i
think that's step one
you know um james gunness has crafted an
insanely wonderful ride and i hope
everybody agrees
and that will mean they want to see more
and james came back for the episodic on
hbo max so we got
eight more episodes of a a dive into
some of the nuances of peacemaker which
is a very dark
horrible place that i it's tough to go
to sometimes
no i just kidding i just don't i was
like whoa
[Laughter]
no no um i i it was fun
it was fun i think the difference
between film and episodic
is you can you can lean in more and you
have more time to tell the story and
especially with this
film with a cast of 25 main characters
there's there's a lot the film doesn't
stop i mean if you ask joel we spent so
much time
ad living and doing outtakes uh you know
you think you give
all this material and like man maybe
some of that stuff is gonna make not one
outtake made the movie the the script is
the movie and i think
there's a little bit more freedom to do
that when you lean into
uh longer episodes right well hopefully
we get another cut of this one then with
with all the ad-libs and stuff
but for both of you what was it like
working with james gunn and what was
your favorite part of shooting
my favorite part of shooting i mean i
love working with james it's uh
it's kind of remarkable being on set
with a guy that that just
has he's gotten all the toys from the
studio you know everyone has so much
trust in james because he's proven
himself so many times and
he's also written the script and it's so
clear when you
read the script that that vision is
crystal clear it's
super tight it's exactly what everyone
wants it to be
and and then you're on set and and you
you see that
you know with all that power because
you know when someone has that much
control they they have a lot of power
what does he do with it he creates a
very playful and
warm environment where everyone feels
free to experiment and take risks and to
joke around
and you know john was talking about that
you know there was a lot of outtakes a
lot of ad-libbing that didn't make it
into the film
but at the same time it creates an
atmosphere
it creates a sense of freedom and and
and
and a sense of risk-taking that really
seeps into the film
and i think that you like the fun that
we had on set
doing those outtakes on that ad-lib even
though only the lines made it into the
film you can tell how much fun we had
saying the actual lines because of that
right john what about you what was it
like for you working with james
james is spectacular really is i i can't
say enough great things about
him and uh so personally he he
he's he does everything extremely well
uh personally he creates an environment
for performers to feel comfortable
so he's he's a great coach in that
regard professionally
he knows everything about everything and
i'm talking like
hey this is the song that's going to
play and it's only going to play from 1
minutes and 19 seconds
to 1 minutes and 43 seconds can i get
that audio right now
and like he's that meticulous about
everything
he really is he's a gifted writer a
gifted
filmmaker and he manages and curates
personalities well like he
it shows whenever he could just call me
up
he's on a very short list of people who
could be like and this happened with the
peacemaker
hey man i have a and i was like yes i
didn't he didn't get the idea
out of his mouth and i've already told
him if he ever needs me to just walk
across the screen and wave
like he's an absolute treat and a
pleasure to work with
uh and all these all the characters that
are in this movie are just so
insane and wildly lovable is there any
character in this film that you guys
nerd out on that isn't your own john uh
i love polka dot man and i really do i
just have a
thing and and i i think david was
awesome as polka dot man and
man i really do love his journey and i
think people are going to enjoy it
double d like i i also
i mean i i love you know so much
stallone brings
so much
on the page uh when i read
king shark you know the first time you
know it's such a funny character and
and i think that was the biggest treat
watching the film because i mean we had
steve agee that also plays economists
and and you know and he was great at
doing all like the sort of physical
comedy
of of king shark but still he's there in
a very humiliating
um you know gray tidies uh
and and this weird like shark head
contraption that he's like lugging
around
and um and you know we had a lot of
laughs around king shark on set but
that was the biggest treat watching the
finished film because that character
really didn't come alive until
you know the animation and then when sly
put his genius touch to it it was really
good
i love your accent american women all
love accents i'm so
jealous the three of you got paid to do
this because it just looked like
an absolute blast all your character
it's like an
island of the perfect misfit toys is
there a character that you guys
nerd out on that isn't your own starting
with you nathan
uh that i nerd out on that isn't my own
um i was really surprised at how much i
nerded out on polka dot man
that is an unassuming character that
it's just it's like when they invented
that guy they just weren't trying that
hard
but i i was really really
surprised i just want to echo that
honestly i would say the same thing i
know that's not the most um
interesting response since since nathan
set it up but i really did
when i saw the movie i i couldn't
believe how much i connected with him
and
uh that's testament to that wonderful
character that
uh david created um
and put on screen and so yeah i don't
know he's he's beautiful
it's kind of amazing to have someone um
this sort of this tragic figure at the
center of this thing and
who who kind of blossoms so so uh freely
and
i know i loved it i thought that was a
stroke of genius from james
to pull him in and have that whole
element with his mother and stuff it was
um
an awesome awesome addition uh i would
tell you because we're now at the bar
and they have both ordered a whiskey
bourbon so i'm not ordering that
my answer will be weasel because when
you think about weasley like surely he's
still underneath all of this weaselness
highly intelligent
and probably has a wardrobe he could
wear at any moment and can contribute to
a conversation
but no the answer is he's really stupid
he's just a weasel
he possibly eats babies weasel is
absolutely iconic as was the beach
sequence
um obviously you don't want to give too
much away what was it like shooting that
beach sequence with just having like
every character there would love to like
go right back around
it's very wet um we're in that water for
real it's real water it's a real beach
uh you know uh in a place that
you know where there shouldn't have been
one um but they created it
and real waves it was kind of epic to
to see what they did for us in that
department and and for the audience you
know we
um i think it needed to to feel as kind
of authentic as possible and to
the fact that they built that jungle and
had us uh you know approaching that
shoreline on a backlot in atlanta
was um kind of incredible it kind of
blew our minds and um
i think it really adds to the to that
whole kind of set piece
um probably a lot of urination happening
in costumes
in the water um well you're in there for
hours at a time
there's stunt people out there that have
been there like for seven
hours i remember saying to one person
like how much
piss do you think is in that pool and
uh you know it's so you have to look
around because like people aren't going
off ten one yeah
we're all just seemed comfortable to
kind of ride it out um
yeah which i you asked you asked me that
question you asked me that question then
i said wait 10 seconds and i said
10 milliliters more than 10 seconds ago
[Laughter]
that's true what was it like for you
guys
working with james gunn i would love to
hear from all three of you like
what was it like working with james gunn
on this nathan
just like old times uh i've been saying
this a couple times today i've had the
opportunity to say this a couple times
uh uh the the one through line through
it all the one consistent thing
is james i think what's changing is the
amount of people who know
and learn that uh we can trust him uh it
was amazing i mean i don't know it's
like it's kind of an obvious
response at this point but he he just
executes
um with such kind of uh humility
and control um and um
and and a sense of humor i mean he it's
amazing to me that
he's able to achieve um what i think is
kind of a masterpiece
uh and yet you let everyone have such a
good time making it
and always feel like there's more room
to play
you know he gets what he needs but um
yeah i don't know there wasn't an
urgency to it there wasn't anything that
just didn't feel like absolute um
you know play time and that's what i
love about being an actor and so when
you get a director at the helm
who um can inspire that uh in
everyone on the set it makes it a really
special experience
james khan is like a man making a
delicious lasagna he has all the
ingredients he selected those
so if you're that floppy pasta then just
be the most floppy pasta in the world
because that's why you were hired
in this case i was the ricotta cheese
right
let's get it it is so good so funny i
could talk about it
four hours my first question is for you
mailing
it's about the beach sequence i know we
can't spoil i don't want to spoil
anything don't want to give too much
away
but how wild was it shooting that beach
sequence with like
every character um i thought i was
dreaming i thought someone was gonna
someone's gonna pinch me and i was gonna
wake up it was pretty i think i said to
nathan a few a few nights on a trap
can we get paid for this just like
really we get paid for this this is a
ball
this is so fun it was yeah it was just
a once in a lifetime opportunity what
getting directed by james gunn working
with these great people
being in like uh temperature controlled
water
like little things jump off things it
was fabulous
so so good um elise what you mentioned
james gunn mailing so elise like what
was it like
working with james gunn and what was
your favorite part about this whole shoe
it was just so special i mean i was a
huge fan of his
before even like getting the chance to
work with him
but he's such a visionary director and
so passionate
for what he does and how he develops a
project
for this one specifically you could see
how dedicated and excited he was and
because
i think these directors they're also
comic fans and they
love genre and stuff like that they
really dig deep when they're directing
projects like this and i think
the fans are going to be blown away by
what he brought and i think that's why
it's so exciting
to see you like saying how much you
enjoyed how much you liked
because that's james's heart i mean it
was so much fun to be on set because of
his manager because of who he is
how inspiring it is but it's all of it
it's james being really passionate about
every single detail and that pays off
when you see the fans getting their mind
blown away by
how amazing it is and what was your
favorite part to film
uh me i think i think it was just being
on sat
like like mainly would say with these
actors i think it's it's it's so much
fun
when there is the scenes that you're
just laughing and the characters are so
sharp and you you bring the comedy you
bring the action i think all of that
it's so exciting i think i love when my
character meets them it's just i
laugh a lot on set i hope people do
laugh when they see the film because it
was really funny
they will and you're so good and i know
you know you're brazilian but your
spanish accent is is so good
melee name question for you you know
what was your favorite part about
filming and what it
what was it like working with james gunn
for you um
i mean i knew a big fan of his work
especially the am the guardians
so i was really stoked to begin to be
doing mondale for the first time she's
like
i think it's the first live
representation of like mondale
and so for me to bring her i really
didn't want to disappoint james so i'd
ask a lot of questions of like
how do you see her doing this and this
and now he was great and
james knows exactly what he wants and he
knows his universe better than anyone
so it was just you know learnt from him
and
it was also very giving and he let
people run wild
i think he'll get a scene that he liked
and then he'll let people just run wild
and say you know let's just
let's just have fun let's just go and do
this and that was hysterical
it was uh one of the most fun sets i've
ever been on
it seems like he gives you know his
actors a lot of freedom to sort of do
what they want
and i think that's why stuff comes out
so good i mean these characters are so
colorful
do you guys have a favorite character
other than your own that you like
nerd out on because there's so many good
ones oh my god it's so funny we've been
laughing
like since we started in the morning
because i'm obsessed about polka dot man
i just love that character i mean
ned i'm definitely gonna be polka dot
man on this halloween i need to figure
out how i'm gonna do that
because it's really i hope they bring
out this clothes because i'm obsessed
about that character i love it
but me it's uh king shark you know he's
like i
like my man yeah he's tall
he's big he's he doesn't say much he's
hairless eats protein with me
it's fabulous that's amazing did you
guys have to do any special training
for this particular film because i feel
like both of your characters are very
physical
i mean i i did some um some work with
the
for the wires and stuff with the stunt
team and
but i was already doing i already
trained anyway and like do physique i
competed before and stuff so i was
already lifting
but i just lifted a lot more heavier
because i knew that mongal was
a lot stronger so and i needed to
maintain that on a set time
and so that was the only thing that i
did was was just to build more muscle
and
manipulate my calories and macros when i
got there
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known
only as project starfish any questions
i walked out of the film and i was like
wow a lot of that movie was in spanish
did you guys talk to james gunn about
that did you know about that and what
was it like working with him we'll start
with um you joaquin
speaking spanish working in spanish is a
good point
a very good point it wasn't a very good
idea from
james gunn because the the the feeling
of the movie is
is it's really really nice really real
you know
and to work with james was a
a big adventure you know all the movie
is a big adventure for
us and and do it in panama
in the rio's forest and in the ocean
oh wow it was a a big big adventure
yeah working with james was amazing i
mean he's he's uh he's very kind
he's uh very passionate and he's a lot
of fun
he creates an amazing vibe on set
like uh every day feels like a party
for real and you're part of something
makes you feel like you're part of
something special
um and then he's very he's very generous
and very kind and
and you feel like he's treating you make
his make he makes you feel
like oh i'm part of a family or
something it was great
it's funny you said family and party
because i feel like that is how you feel
when you're watching the suicide squad
that this is just like
an awesome insane ride that you never
want to get off
the characters are so insane they're so
lovable is there a character other than
your own that you guys were nerding out
on that you just like really really
loved
i mean me personally i love harley queen
i mean she's
she's the sum
of of of everything she's um totally
crazy
she is but then nice but then generous
but tender but
aggressive like she's the mix the
perfect cocktail of all of this
crazy crazy characters um i would say
she's my favorite yeah
i love the king shark
it's amazing when he he moves here
his arms and when he speaks it's amazing
for me
what was it like being around filming
king shark with sylvester stallone on
set
the actor is really really tall you know
and it was a big beautiful because
you're
you're really talking with a big shark a
real
big heart all the movie was
really really funny it's so funny um
going back to because you mentioned
harley quinn juan you guys have a lot
you and margot robbie have such awesome
chemistry
and such amazing scenes together what
was it like working with margot robbie
it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
i mean
just watching her playing harley queen
and getting in and out of the character
and i mean she's this is a character
that she's played many times and she
knows so well
and it was beautiful to watch how she
can you know get into the depths of the
character and then
you know playing that she has she has a
scene
and he feels like she's moved and then
she goes crazy again
it was um just being there watching her
playing that part it was a lot of fun
and then she's very generous and very
kind as an actress so i had a great time
i'm gonna get you out of real life i'm
going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
sometimes